so many people who want to be famous
they're doing stunts and tricks and
things just to gain followers you're
different if I get 10 million people
that watch something and cry and then
turn off their phone and go back to life
like what really impact is that like
sure that's powerful but I want 10
million people to actually go out and do
something
brand of what he calls undercover
kindness a lot of your videos are you
going out to giving money to people who
demonstrate kindness and generosity the
whole point is to encourage people to
always be kind and my favorite thing
about these people that pass these
kindness tests is they don't really know
what's coming and they've been kind
their whole life that guy that gave me
that hug for example the spotlight was
never on him but now one moment it was
captured and now he's got 50 Grand and
he's back with his family so that's
really the beauty of it